mes adversaires sont redoutables
[Applaudissements]
ça va être difficile de gagner
mais quand tu as le sentiment que c'est
perdu d'avancé et que tu entends fuir
rappelle toi comment tu en est arrivé là
[Musique]
ils sont présents j'ai pas perdu mon
temps je fais pas perdu ma technique
on va bientôt se battre contre fantômes
il arrive de los angeles
on accueille au tom cruise
[Applaudissements]
seul véritable obstacle il est juste là
c'est seulement pendant que vous dansez
que vous avez l'impression des monts le
maître du monde
[Applaudissements]
sky cruz ne disparaîtra pas
[Musique]
vous vous souhaitez impassible
peu importe qu'on gagne ou qu'on perde
j'aurai réussi à marquer les esprits
[Musique]